what are the three greatest scrap albums  of all time  um I guess it's easy to be Illmatic I  just feel bad that I'm just say all New  York albums and I wanna at least say one  West Coast album or something else but  no I got it okay man it's nice Illmatic  Wu-Tang Enter the 36 Chambers in my deep  hello Nerf  who if you had to pick a West Coast like  what's the three West Coast albums if I  could do that okay I'll do um any E40  album you can pick any E40 I haven't put  it in there of course you're gonna have  to say The Chronic and uh  um I'm gonna just throw one out there  there's some that I really like that's  on my own terms and it would be rans  cast solo nice how many New York  [Laughter]  your first La album about seven  like that about I mean I forgot Spice  One the very first spice one album it's  done so much in my life